one of the best dessert combos in my
opinion i think in her opinion as well
is fruit and chocolate and if you've
never had a frozen banana dipped in
chocolate allow me to introduce you to
lelana's bananas okay owner leah
gutierrez is here to change your life to
change my life jc's life because he's
been eyeing
these things okay now first i want to
ask you because he had the idea that you
would be driving in a banana car
confirm that you do not well we have a
banana rolla oh see wow
okay and a banana van okay right pink
you can't miss it all right we like that
right pink must be your favorite color
possibly you look good in it okay so
let's talk about
your business here how did you come up
with this what inspired leland's bananas
so it's super corny but i really was
just on a mission to spread happiness i
didn't know what that was or what it
looked like until i was walking through
my kitchen one day there was a banana
sitting on the counter and i realized in
that moment it looked like it was
smiling back at me
so i ran to the store i bought every
kind of chocolate i possibly could and
here we are four years later that is a
great story i was not expecting that
that's such a good story now just
explain for anyone who doesn't know you
know the frozen banana concept
it seems self-explanatory but there's an
opportunity yes no there really is a lot
of people think it's very simple when
you start dipping bananas and chocolate
it gets very complicated very quickly it
dries faster than you would expect so
getting everybody to be able to roll
them through all the toppings before it
hardens is quite a task okay you're
talking about toppings i see fruity
pebbles so that's what i'm going for yes
please that is my thing so tell me about
the creation and the toppings and how it
all works when they come into your shore
so we have a shop and you can come in we
start with any size banana that you like
we have everything from a free kids pop
all the way up to a whole banana we dip
it in the ghirardelli chocolate of your
choice and then we have about 28
different toppings to choose from so you
can absolutely customize as much as you
want and then drizzles of course because
what's a banana without a drizzle
marshmallow nutella all the good stuff
caramel i feel like i mean obviously
this is a dessert but it's also banana
so i don't feel bad at all so that one
right there is only about 80 calories
wow see this is so good and it's
refreshing obviously for the summer
but besides the shop you have the cart
let's talk about the car yes so the cart
is rentable we do everything from
birthday parties weddings corporate
events it's a small cart it fits through
a standard doorway into an elevator and
we actually bring the cart to you dip
them on the spot so every single guest
gets to customize it also does mini
banana splits and our very famous banana
pudding
and then if you can't rent the cart then
we have the ice box that is available
for rental we pre-dip and individually
package every banana so you can set it
out by the pool and just hand them out
as you like and that is our very famous
banana pudding
we have 45 seconds
we have 45 seconds so as i try the
banana pudding let's talk about what
else is on the menu you've got gifts too
we do gift delivery six days a week
monday through saturday we deliver from
north las vegas all the way to boulder
city uh we show up it's our team our
banana squad delivers in the banana van
and we try and snap a photo of every
person that receives a box send it to
the send to the sender and uh it's the
happiest fruit that smiles back
okay natalia our producer she was
wondering about this banana pudding so
this just
i have to say
this is good this is really good
and i'm comparing it to like my
grandmother's casino and this is good we
get like
banana pudding connoisseurs from south
carolina from new york they are from all
over the place and we have the stamp of
approval so wow well good job
congratulations on all your success
shout out to lealandsbananas.com for
more information
we'll send it to you
[Music]